>> All right.
Welcome to the afternoon session.
We have two speakers now,
both talks for 20 minutes.
The first one is Suchin
Gururangan, is that,
>> Yup.
>> Close? With
Annotation Artifacts
in Natural Language
and Inference Data.
>> All right. Hey, everyone.
My name is Suchin,
a graduate student in
University of Washington.
This is going to be project
called Annotation Artifacts
in Natural Language
Inference Data.
Here with my co-first
author Swabha Swayamdipta,
and this is joint
work with Omer Levy,
Roy Schwartz, Sam Bowman
and Noah Smith.
So, who here works with
crowdsource annotations,
or maybe works at datasets
on crowdsource annotations?
Yeah. So, this is
a really popular,
sort of area of NLP,
and it really drives
a lot of modern NLP.
So, we're usually
given some text,
we have a model, and we
have some output here.
It's easy to forget
that there are humans behind
the text and the data that
we feed our models to.
Those annotators,
because they are human,
they have their own biases.
They have their own beliefs
about the world.
They have personal motives.
They have their own
cultural backgrounds,
and this affects
the distributions
that we see in our data.
There's been a lot of
conversation about how biases
affects downstream,
some subtle applications,
but sort of long-running theme of
this talk is that biases
also affect how we evaluate
models or design of our tasks.
So, the story sort
of starts with the natural
language inference task,
which I think a lot of people
here are familiar with.
Basically, you're
given two sentences,
a premise and a hypothesis,
and the goal is to
determine whether
that premise entails
that hypothesis.
So, there are three categories.
So, for example, you're
given, on the premise,
North West NLP workshop
which is being held at
Microsoft headquarters.
You have an entailment category,
the workshop is in
Redmond because
that's definitely true
given this premise.
A contradiction that
Amazon assessing
the workshop because
that can't be true,
and neutral example that
Satya Nadella is attending
the workshop at Memphis here.
But, so these are
relatively well-defined
classes and
it's really up for annotation.
We've had a lot of
really great performance
on this task over
the past few years.
The Stanford NLI and
multiNLI datasets
released in past couple years,
and people have been getting
scores in the 70s and 80s
across these two datasets.
So, a newcomer to
this particular area
of NLP might see
these scores and be like,
"Okay, there's not
really much else to
do in NLI, and what
am I doing here?"
But I think the results of
this paper kind of show
that there is a lot to do.
Most NLI models, especially
the top-performing ones,
sort of represent
both premise and
the hypothesis in some joint way,
feat that joint
representations down
to a classifier to predict
those three labels.
What we found very
interestingly is that if you
completely disregard the premise
and only consider the hypothesis,
only feed the hypothesis
into that classifier,
and make the same
predictions, you can do
really well on this task.
The classifier that we use in
this particular
experiment was fastText
which is not the self text
categorization model
from Facebook,
models as words as bigrams,
unigrams, very, very simple.
We were able to get
67 percent accuracy on SNLI,
and about 55 percent
accuracy on multiNLI.
This is kind of harrowing.
This tells us that
those datasets aren't
really doing what they're
supposed to be doing.
We don't really need to
learn entailment to perform
about 2x above
our majority baselines.
So, the sort of projects
that we embarked on
was really to answer
this question of why
we're able to do so
well on this task with
just the hypothesis.
We showed that elicited
annotations induce
lexical clues which we call
annotation artifacts that
reveal the entailment class.
We showed that supervised models,
especially the
top-performing ones,
exploit these annotation
artifacts in making predictions.
We present the wider implications
for model evaluation
and task design.
So, even though this talk
is very centered
around NLI data, hopefully,
anyone who's working with
creating datasets using
crowdsource annotators
or evaluating models
in general can benefit
from these results.
So, the first argument
we had in our paper was
that there is this
annotation artifacts
in NLI hypotheses
that heavily correlate
with the entailment class.
I'm going to walk through
how we showed that,
but I think it's prudent to think
about how these data sets are
generated in the first place.
So, essentially, SNLI
and multiNLI are
generated through
sort of captions and
source texts for multiple genres
that are fed to annotators on
MTurk who were then
asked to create
those three hypotheses:
entailment,
contradiction, and neutral.
There's a real focus
on scale here,
both from the annotators'
perspective as well as the task
designers' perspective.
The task designer wants
as many examples as
possible so we can feed those in
our data hungry neural nets,
and annotators want to
maximize their word,
annotate as many
examples as possible.
SNLI and multiNLI achieved
about one million
high-agreeing examples,
and this is really
great for that,
for this particular area
of NLP because
previous datasets
either relied on
expert annotators or relied
on very specific theories of
entailment that were
very hard to scale.
In this paper, under
this framework,
we showed that
annotators are sort
of trying to maximize
their efficiency
in creating these hypotheses,
and thus introducing
these sort of heuristics and
tricks to create examples that
our models are trained on.
So, I'm going to go
walk through some of
the artifacts that we
found in the paper.
We quantitatively justify
them in the paper,
and there are
a lot more artifacts
that we show in the paper.
So, if you're interested,
definitely check them out.
So, entailment artifacts
included generalizations.
We saw a lot of entailment
hypotheses that were associated
with premises like some men and
boys are playing frisbee
in a grassy area.
Entailments having
generalizations over
entities in that text,
people playing frisbee outdoors.
We also see shortening where
specific words are
removed from the premise.
For example here, the word
shirt and the word
green are removed just to
create a entailment hypothesis.
Neutral artifacts
contained purpose clauses.
For example, if two dogs are
running through a field,
the neutral hypothesis that was
created was some puppies are
running to catch a stick.
Basically, an ambiguous
situation was created
by applying a reason
to the premise.
Modifiers are also really
popular where people just
stuck sort of adjectives
or superlatives in
front entities in the text,
in the premise to sort of
create the neutral hypothesis.
Contradictions have very,
very consistent trends,
negation was really popular.
This is one of
my favorite examples because
the premise is very intricate
and like complicated,
has a lot of stuff going on.
But the contradiction
that they chose was
nobody has a cat
which is like really,
really simple and it's
a valid form of entailment,
but it's something that
models can really,
really easily pick up on.
Cats are also really popular
in the contradictions.
The Flickr30k dataset,
which is what
the SNLI data was derived from,
contains a lot of dogs.
So, people thought cats
were contrary to dogs,
I sort of disagree with that,
having a cat and a dog.
But this is sort of
the human belief and
the sort of biases that
get imbued into the dataset
based on people's
previous experience.
So, we've shown that
artifacts exists,
and the next argument
of the paper
is that supervised models,
especially the
top-performing ones,
exploit them to
make a predictions.
The way that we
showed this, is we
revisited the original model
that motivated all this work.
The hypothesis-only
classifier that
we're able to do really
well on SNLI with
and multiNLI with.
We basically fed in the test data
for both multiNLI and SNLI,
and if the hypothesis-only
classifier was
able to get that example
right by just using
the hypothesis,
we consider that example easy.
If it wasn't able to do it,
so we consider it hard.
So, in this way, we partition
the test data into
hard and easy subsets,
and we also revisited
the models that I
originally showed that did
well on SNLI and multiNLI.
We basically tested
these models on
the easy and hard subsets
and saw how they did.
We basically showed that
easy examples drove
NLI performance.
If you see a graph here,
this is the accuracy
of the same models.
On the full data, we get
about 87 percent accuracy.
If you look at just
the hard examples,
the ones that hypothesis-only
classifier was not
able to get correct,
the accuracy of
those models drops
pretty significantly,
10 to 20 points.
If you look the easy examples,
those models did
really, really well.
So, this kind of shows us
the majority of the examples that
these models are
able to get right or
the ones that have
annotation artifacts.
We get very similar results
in multiNLI too,
check out the paper if
you want to learn more.
So, given these results,
I have a few closing thoughts.
You can think of annotation
artifacts as sampling bias.
It's possible that, so I mean,
it's crucial to know that
none of these examples are
invalid forms of
entailment, right?
They're all correct, they're
just dominating the dataset,
these very easy
lexical heuristics
are dominating the data set.
So, it's possible that like in
a good way to solve this problem,
is to sort of normalize
the distribution of strategies
that are used to create
entailment hypothesis.
Not only using
these lexical heuristics,
but also using things
like world knowledge
or political perspective
or other forms
of entailment that don't
readily exists in that dataset.
Another really important
thing to realize is
that the reason this
is a problem is that,
a lot of these models are
very lexically-driven,
and they're very susceptible
to these artifacts.
What we want is a very
general representation of
entailment that is invariant
to these artifacts.
But what we see is that
these models are making
lexical associations
between words and
surface patterns like Ihashon was
mentioning, to these labels.
So we have to really
rethink about
how we're modeling entailment,
to try to create
representations that
are really invariant to
these problems that we see.
Also this is not just about NLI.
This paper I think is
a child of a series of
papers that have come out
recently thinking
about datasets and
critiquing how datasets
are either created,
how models can be easily
broken by introducing
adversarial examples.
I think that more work
like this should be done,
I think it's an important
part of doing NLP that
we're empirically driven and that
we're sure that what
we're measuring and
evaluating models for are
actually what they're learning.
Lastly, I think progress in
NLI has been overestimated.
I think that there are a lot of
open questions that sort
of result to this work,
that really focus on how
we do better annotation,
how can we direct annotators to
avoid these simple heuristics.
When generating examples,
can we employ some sort of
automated real-time sort
of reward system
that disincentivizes
using simple heuristics.
Are there alternatives
to elicitation
that can help us build
entailment datasets?
I think that there are
a ton more open questions,
and I'd love to talk
to people about it,
if you're interested.
We released the hard benchmarks
on Kaggle and SNLI.
So If you're interested in
national good inference
definitely i encourage you
to check these benchmarks
out and test your models on
both the full benchmarks as
well as these hard
subsets to see if
you generalize across
these artifacts.
Thanks. Here's
the link to my paper.
>> Okay. We actually have
lots of time for questions.
Okay.
>> Thanks. Also are there
interesting patterns to
the hard examples or
are they more diverse?
>> Yes. So we didn't
include this in
the paper because it's
a very hard problem
but when you look at
the hard subsets,
it's not that they don't
contain artifacts,
it's that they contain
very different types
of skews from the easy subset.
So for example, maybe you'd have
a lot of examples in the hard
subset where like "not".
The word "not",
negation is associated
with a different class like
neutrals or entailments.
So it's a kind of an open
question about sort of how
we utilize "hard training
data" and the best way is there
a way to remove these artifacts.
Yeah, it's hard to tell.
>> So I was thinking
specifically with
the example of negation,
that seems one that's maybe
would be natural to
contradiction and maybe
the reason people are making
the sentences like that is
because that's such a natural way
to produce contradiction.
So in that way it seems could
be a natural bias that you
wouldn't want to remove.
>> Right. Yes.
>> Like some of them
like cat obviously.
That is like a problem from
the initial data is that it
seems but some of
them seem less. Yes.
>> Yeah a hundred
percent. I mean,
none of these examples are
invalid forms of entailment.
They're all valid.
I think the key is when
we're evaluating our models,
we got to make sure
if we are saying
that we're making a lot
of progress on NLI,
what are we actually
making progress on.
Are we making progress on
these easy less cool heuristics
or are we actually
making progress
on my General entailment?
Right. So it's really
a question of how we
build our data-sets.
So we're evaluating our progress
on these tasks and
the best way possible.
>> So you defined
your easy examples as
the one that's
your basic model was
able to classify correctly.
But do you make a difference
between the ones that
the basic examples
are that actually
easy versus the ones that
the model is picked up by chance?
>> We don't make
that distinction.
I think there's
actually some work
that my co-authors while
those about to work
on with creating
better partitions of
easy and hard subsets,
by using maybe like
an adversarial model that is
sort of online trying to
classify both easy
and hard examples
while another model is trying to
actually perform entailment
and sort of predictions.
I think this is really
just a good first step
into trying to
build a better easy hard subset.
But there's definitely
a lot more work to be done
to create those partitions
more accurately.
>> So you said
this paper was part of
kind of a series of papers.
I'm just kind of curious,
is there other research
going on into artefacts and
annotations potentially
for different problems
but similar data sources?
>> Yes. I personally haven't
seen much work in this area,
I think there's
generally been a lot of
work on how- there was actually
a lot of parallel work
that had been done
with other groups on
the analyte dataset showing
that not only are there biases
with these sort of
heuristics that people use,
there's also biases in
the context of like,
people are introducing
stereotypes into
the data and I think those
are separate problems.
I'd say that this is definitely
nascent work and there
need to be some more work
done in this area too.
>> Awesome. Thanks.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. One last question.
>> More of a statement
than a question.
One strategy we've had to weigh,
we rely on Mechanical Turk
for a lot of language data.
One strategy we've had is to
actually get users to
filter themselves out,
so you get them,
you ask them questions that
can become wrong or say
their answers have to be
XYZ length to your negation
for example, for instance.
There might be
further research and
strategies into that,
I suppose. Any thoughts on that?
>> Yeah, I feel like
nowadays there's
a lot of friction in trying to
create the real-time interaction
between annotators,
and when you're creating
these really huge data sets,
a lot of times you're
not able to identify
these problems until
after the fact's,
and then it's too costly to go
back and recreate the data set.
So, I think real-time
way to review things,
examples in batches,
or something like you
propose would be
really influential.
>> It's an expensive problem.
>> Yeah.
>> Antoine, are you ready?
>> Okay, let's thank
the speaker then.
>> Suchin sort of teach
a lot of what I'm going
to talk about in this talk,
which is pretty much
Neural Networks,
mouths without brains, also
listeners without brains,
because it goes both ways and
I'm going to talk about how
we can give them a brain.
So, Yejin talked a lot
about recipes and I'm
going to do so as well,
I usually love to give
this talk right before
lunch because it's nice
to see people squirm.
Let's start by having you think
about making an apple pie.
When you bake a pie, there's
a process that you follow in
order to compose
your raw ingredients
into a final product.
Intermediate steps such
as slicing apples,
cooking them, placing them in
a pie sheet and then
baking the pie,
all have to be correctly
navigated in the right order
and with the right
intermediate constructs if
you're going to make something
that's both edible and tasty.
Understanding that process
requires many common senses
causal inferences to be made
and remembered later on.
First one's we slice the apples,
we have to understand some notion
that their shape has changed.
When we saute them for a bit,
we now know that
their cookedness has
changed and that there
temperature
has also likely
changed to be warm.
Also despite having
caused these new changes,
we also still have to remember
that they've been
cut from before,
that shape is still the same.
We're not going back to
having a raw apple that's
had a completely new set
of things done to it.
Then when we add them
to the pie sheet,
we have to understand that
there's actually a new entity
that's been created from our
sliced and cooked apples,
and the dough that we've
now combined it with.
Finally, once we throw
it into the oven,
we have to know that
that combination of apples and
pie sheet is now
going to be cooked.
So, if we think about how
current intelligent agents
might parses this information,
current ubiquitous
approach using LSTM,
encode all the words
into some type of
sentence representation
that's usually
a single vector or
a group of vectors,
and you hope that that
information can then be queried
from that representation
in a later step.
That's not necessarily
what happens though,
while LSTMs are powerful
representational tools,
they don't do much more
than encodes surface
word patterns,
and they generally haven't
been shown to capture
more complex world
dynamics that might be
necessary for reasoning or
some other downstream task
that you want.
Some more complex models;
memory networks or
entity networks,
do allow for more
fine-grained state
representations because
they generally split
this encoded context
across memory cells,
which might allow you to retain
processed information better
or encodes certain parts
of your contexts
in different ways.
But they still don't capture
any information beyond what's
explicitly stated in the text,
they're just learning
text patterns and
learning how to represent
those in a particular way.
So, problem with
these approaches then is that,
the models we're building
aren't ones that
currently learn
contexts representations,
that track the state of
the world with all of
the information that's needed
to perform downstream tasks.
Most neural state
representations encode
only surface patterns
between tokens and they
generally devolve into encoding
the most simple pattern
that they can in order to get
at the tasks that
they're trying to do.
So, what might be a strong
enough representation for
some applications might not
be good for another one
right after,
and so the reasoning that
you use in one application
might not be useful for what
happens next in another one.
So, what we really want
ultimately is for
the representations that
we learn to understand some
underlying dynamic
about the world,
and not just a dynamic
about the task that
we're training it on.
So, this is why we
decided to approach
texts understanding from
different paradigm.
Understanding
the state of the world
means understanding that that
world is entity centric,
and it involves identifying
the state changes that
those entities experience.
Many of these state changes
however might be
knowledge based as
opposed to text-based,
so instead of being
explicitly mentioned in text,
there might be an expectation of
prior common sense knowledge
that your model
actually needs to know.
So, in this work
more specifically,
we're going to address
the following challenges.
We're going to design a simulator
that's entity aware and that
focuses on capturing information
that describes
changes to entities.
So, after reading any
sentence in a recipe,
we're going to choose an entity,
apply a transformation
to it and then we're
going to update a running
representation of its state.
Later, we should be able
to predict attributes of
the state based on
an embedding that we're
tracking and storing for.
Second, we're going to integrate
common sense knowledge about
physical state changes into
the neural network by
adding knowledge about
action causality as
a structural bias.
So, we're going to
do this by allowing
a predefined set of
action embeddings to cause
changes to our entity states.
So, raw text is actually
only going to be used
to select entities
and select actions,
and the actual simulation of
the events that are described
in the text is going
to be done by applying
these learned action functions
to the entity state embeddings.
So, then the ultimate
goal is really
to learn a set of
good actions functions that
can consistently induce
the correct state changes
and entities based on the
text that's being read.
We're going to do this
in a two-step process.
First, in order to develop
a neural architecture that can
learn these effects of actions
that they have on entities,
we're going to crowdsource a set
of action state mappings,
and then we're going
to see how we can use
this crowdsource information
to learn the parameters of
a neural network that is
structured to capture
the inductive bias of how
actions affect
state changes and entities.
So, to crowdsource, action-state
mapping's not
particularly interested,
but we extracted
a set of 380 verbs
from a cooking domain that
are mentioned fairly frequently,
and then we manually
compiled a set of
six state changes that
actions could entail.
So, location,
composition, cleanliness,
cookedness,
temperature and shape,
and by using the state changes
as a supervision,
we can learn the transformations
that actions should
induce in entities.
So, for each of the 384 actions,
we actually crowdsource
steady-state changes
that action tends to
induce in entities.
So, for an action like cuts,
we're generally going to expect
to see a change in shape.
For an action like boil,
we're going to see a change in
cookedness and in temperature,
so you can have multiple state
changes for the same action.
Rinse involves change in
cleanliness and stirring might
involve a change in composition.
Now that we have this action
state mapping knowledge,
we come up with this model
which we call
the neural process network
because it models the processes
that are described in text,
which is a new
neural network that
decomposes the state tracking
task into one of tracking
actions in entities and learning
the transformations
that those actions
are going to induce
in the entities.
So, to do this,
the model actually
keeps track of the set
of state embeddings
for the entities that
it can change
throughout the process,
and a known set of
action functions that
can actually change
those entities,
and one of which
corresponds to each of
the actions that we
crowdsourced earlier.
So, let me go over what
the model is going to
try to accomplish
to a high level.
In the interest of
time, I'm not going to
go into too many
details about it,
because I really want
to get to the results,
but I'm actually going to
focus in on a couple of parts
that I think are
super interesting.
So, the first thing that
happens is typical,
is that it's going to
read in a sentence using
some type of recurrent
neural network such as
the GRU and it's going
to build a sentence
representation for it.
So, in this case,
I'm going to use
this running example of cooking
the beef on the pan to
highlight a couple of things.
Using this encoded
representation from the encoder,
it's going to select entities
that are going to be
changed by the events
in the sentence using
an attention mechanism,
that computes a binary choice
over each individual entity
and this allows us to
choose multiple entities
to be changed in
a particular sentence.
So, in this sentence for
cook the beef in the pan,
it would choose to beef entity.
Then the model is going
to select an action
that it thinks is
changing the entities it
selected earlier in the sentence
by computing an attention
over the action functions
that were initialized
at the start.
So here, it might select
the action like cook,
it might also select
an action like
put because they
recognize the pan is
usually associated with
the location change.
Then inside this
applicator function,
it's actually going to compute
a bi-linear projection
between this action embedding
and this entity embedding,
and come up with a new state
embedding that it thinks
is a reflection of how
this entity it's selected
earlier has been changed.
So, in essence, this is the step
that understands that now,
some cooking action has been
applied to the beef from earlier.
From that, it should actually
be able to tell us what
about this entity has changed
using a set of classifiers,
one for each of
the state change types
that we were tracking earlier.
So, in this case, the beef
is now hot, it's now cooked.
Now the pan, meanwhile,
there hasn't really been
a change in cleanliness at all.
Finally, it updates
this information
in the entity state embeddings,
so the entity states reflect
the state changes that
the entities have experienced.
Like I said, this involves
a lot neural networks,
I'm not going to go into
every single neurons
specifically but
here's a couple of things I
want to highlight about it.
First, when the model predicts
the state changes that
in entities experienced,
the errors from predicting
those state changes get
back-propagated
back all the way to
the action embeddings
in the action selector,
which allows us to learn
representations of
actions that are
more likely to induce
the correct state changes
in the future.
Second point I want to highlight
is that when we update
the entity state
representations in the memory,
we update each slot proportional
to what it's original attention
was when we selected that entity,
and what this does is that
it allows us to model
interesting compositional
effects when
two entities are
mixed, for example.
So, because both slots might
be selected at 100 percent,
we're going to overwrite
both of them with
the same embedding that
we got at the output,
which allows us to pretty much
reflect that these two things are
now the same entity because
they've been combined
in a mixture.
The last thing I want
to point out is this idea
of recurrent attention.
So, when it's sentence such as
"Cook the beef in the pan",
it's pretty clear which entities
that should be the beef.
But if I all of a sudden
changed that sentence to
"cook it in a pan",
all of a sudden,
it could refer to
pretty much any entity,
it really depends
on what has been
seen earlier because
it's a co-reference.
So, what we want to do
instead is that
we're going to allow
the model to attend to
previous attention steps,
so that it can select entities
that have been selected prior,
an attention over attentions,
in order to be able to select
entities that were seen before.
So, there is
a lot of details around
Datasets and training,
but I encourage you to
look at the paper for
those it's a very interesting
paper I wrote it,
but what we've done here,
is we've sort of done at
a high level is to build
a simulator that captures
the Dynamics of
actions being taken
to the cooking domain as
it reads recipe lines.
So the underlying task
is really to read
a recipe and be able to
predict the entities
that are changed,
and the state changes that
they undergo in each step.
So, obviously this leads to
a great task of
state change prediction,
and we use the accuracy and F1
of predicting the correct
state changes,
and we weigh them by the accuracy
of predicting
the correct entities,
and were better than competitive
Neural baselines such as a GRU,
which kind of we would
expect to be, as well as,
the recurrent Entity Network
which is one of
the best models on the bAbi
datasets from
machine comprehension.
When we look at how well
we choose entities,
we see where this improvement
actually comes from,
so in the leftmost column
we see that we have
a much better F1 score
of predicting
the correct entities
at every step,
and this actually is not
necessarily because of how
well we predict raw entities,
so we do do a bit
better when we look at
recall of predicting
the raw ingredients,
compared to the two baselines,
but it really, which is
raw ingredients would be
something like predicting
cut the tomatoes,
and even something like
co-reference or
lighted arguments,
but the big difference
is really how we
do in predicting
composed entities.
So, if you think
about something like
combine the water
and flour in a bowl,
at the next step, if
know we have some
like stir the mixture
until dough forms.
It's really tough to know that
that dough refers to
this water and this flour,
and we pretty much
double performance
that these baselines can actually
manage at predicting
these types of
compositional entities,
which is going to help us
do a better job of tracking
the state of entities overall.
Just looking at examples here,
melt butter in medium saucepan
overheating the first step.
Most models should be able to
predict that the
butter's being changed,
and the second step
removed from heat,
there's an elided argument,
but we're able to
predict that anyway.
The third step's stir in oats,
sugar, flour, all
these fun things,
we still understand
that the butter
is still there and
needs to be combined
with these things.
If we look at something
even more complex.
Step one, brown meat in oil
until it's brown on all sides.
Step two, pour off grease.
We actually get this wrong,
we predict that the oil
should leave the mixture
at this point,
you know the gold says none,
but if you think
about grease and oil,
probably fairly similar
embeddings, overall.
And so, it's conceivable
that it could have
left at the same time.
Then in the next step nothing
particularly interesting,
we predict all these
directly named entities,
but then the interesting part
is in the step four,
where the line is bring to
boil and turn very low.
Cover, simmer
about one and half hours
or until meat is tender.
Meat should be fairly easy to
predict as an ingredient
that's being used here,
it's explicitly
mentioned in the text,
what's interesting is that
we actually predict all of
these other ingredients
that were combined
with the meat in
the previous step.
So it's actually
managed to figure out
that this is actually
a composition of
all these entities,
and it predicts them all
together at the same time.
And to show this effect
a bit more quantitatively,
if you remember how we
select an update entities,
which is a set of entities,
we average them and then we apply
the action function to them,
and then we write
the new embedding
back to the correct memory slot,
weighted by the original
attention on that slot.
So, if two entities are selected,
their embedding
representations should
usually move a lot closer
to each other in embedding space,
because they're both
being partially
overwritten by the same vector.
As it turns out if we look at
the percentage change
in cosine similarity,
of entity embeddings
that are being combined,
we can see that they're
generally moving
a lot closer to each
other in embedding space.
Now for the skeptics among you,
you can tell me that that's
obvious if you select
all of them at
the same time at the first step
they'll all move
a lot closer to each
other in embedding space,
so we should actually
look at which
ones aren't supposed to do that.
And it turns out, if we
superimpose that graph
on this one,
we can see that if you
just actually select
entities that aren't supposed to
be combined in that step,
they don't move close together
at all in embedding space.
There's obviously a bit of noise
that leaks here and there,
but with a good cut off
you could probably get
rid of most of that.
So, we're simulating
entity effects fairly
nicely, what about actions?
While this entire model runs on
the premise that
action functions are applied,
entity embeddings that
induce state changes,
if it works correctly,
we would expect
semantically similar actions
to end up having similar
action function beddings.
And the hypothesis is true if we
compare action functions
and embedding space,
they end up in
a fairly nice part,
so the cut action is near
the slice split snap splash,
mashing ends up being your
spreading pure and squeezing.
So the internals of
our models seem to be
looking at the same patterns
that we're trying to replicate.
And finally, our
state representations
have to be useful
for downstream task.
We have to show there are
similar and can encode
an advantageous representation of
the process being described,
using the world information
that we've provided to it.
So we applied
our state's Simulation
Model two recipe step generation.
So at each step we use
the state embeddings
of the entities,
to cede an LSTM generator,
and we changed it to generate
the next step in the recipe.
And across the board, our model
represented here in Orange,
does better than
competitive baseline such as
seek-to-seek or an
attentive seek-to-seek,
and it's consistent across
metrics such as blue, rouge,
as well as these
metrics VF1 and SCF1,
where we pretty much
look at whether we
generate the correct action
in the next sentence,
or the correct state change
in the next sentence.
And interestingly, one of
the baseline that
we ran was using
the entity state embeddings from
the recurrent entity
network tracker.
So we used the tracker of the
recurrent [inaudible] network that
baseline which is also sort
of learning this entity.
This fine-grained
entity representation,
and we see how well
the state embeddings
that it encodes due on this task.
And it does worse than the NMP
and across all metrics.
Indicating that
the action-oriented simulation
that we're using
actually plays a role in
encoding better stay
representations for
downstream or at generation.
And a quick example, if we see
this recipe start generation
with an ingredient
such as butter,
you know, the first step
is to preheat
the oven to 425 degrees.
These neural networks
immediately jump to
pretty common answers for
something that requires
preheating in oven like lately,
greasing baking pan with oil,
or combining all ingredients
will mix, and mix well.
Our model knows that if you have
some butter, and it's raw,
you're probably going to melt it,
which is exactly what
the references is as well.
So the takeaways text
only gets you so far,
you really need
a model of the world,
to do good understanding.
You can encode these priors
into a neural network
architecture,
and that model the world
can be learned from data.
In future work, we're
looking at stories,
we're looking at dialogues,
we're looking at
scientific processes,
and we're also
looking at what type
of models of the world can
we encode to do better on
these downstream tasks.
And luckily for me,
I work in a group
that makes a lot of
these models of the world,
between verb physics,
connotation frames,
and all these other things.
There's a lot of data that
we have to actually create
these world models to do
better in stories, dialogues,
and scientific processes, so
we're looking at encoding
those into this
pipeline. Thank you.
>> Since there is a coffee break
right after that,
I guess we have
some time for questions.
>> I think there's
one right there.
>> Thanks, great presentation.
I was just wondering if,
because you are working
on food recipes,
just because of
the nature of food that
you're you're picking up like,
single sense types of words.
So when you use that word entity,
if you're kind luckily
referring to
a particular sentence,
whereas if you put this into the
wild you might think things like,
the house blew up
when he was cooking
meth or salt in my wounds-
>> Great example.
>> Or scratching
the cherry car paint job.
>> Yeah. So, the question
is to simplify down,
we'll just generalize.
So if we were looking at
different domains
besides just cooking.
Will something like
this even work?
So I would say that the
simplified version of it which we
had for here with a fairly
simple model of the world,
where we just had
six state changes applied to
385 verbs in the
cooking domain works.
While you might need
a much larger world to actually
simulate for another task
so that you can.
You can actually capture
all of those effects.
One of the things we're
working on is using
larger lexicon of
verbs, as well as,
a larger set of state mappings
that those verbs can induce,
for tasks such as
dialogue and stories.
>> Seems like this is a natural
for incorporating
outside ontologies.
You learned all this just
from reading recipes,
but if you tried incorporating
ontologies to know about
things you haven't seen
in recipes before?
>> What type of ontologies
are you suggesting?
>> Just a dictionary
of what a carrot is,
in that you never saw [inaudible]
recipe, but the ontologies [inaudible].
>> Yeah. So, we didn't
do it in this work,
in future work, it's one
of the things that
we're looking at.
A lot of the lexicons
were trying to look
at as being a model of our world,
are in fact ontologies
that look at
how different verbs,
what effects they use.
So we're using a lot of frame
structures as models
of our world.
>> Okay the last question.
>> So great doc.
So, you did not elaborate
on the dataset much.
I was wondering, so
there are a lot of
these videos of cooking online
or even some of
these recipes have like
intermediate photos of
the different states.
Could you do some kind
of multi-modal reasoning
or this kind of?
>> Yeah, that was one of
the goals that we
were sort of looking
at for future work,
is how to integrate this great
and expansive data source
of video and images,
and how we could integrate that,
and we're actually working
with collaborators like
Cornell right now,
who are looking into
that sort of stuff,
pretty much how you can represent
the intermediate state
using images,
as opposed to
maybe CrowdSource labels.
So, we're pretty excited about
what's going on with that work,
there is some amazing new
datasets and hopefully,
we'll be able to do
something with it.
>> Okay, let's thank
the speaker again.